♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est la chose qui
me passionne le plus.
Il n'y a rien qui me "drive"
autant qautant qautant qautant .
- L'un est ingénieur, l'autre
préposé à l'entretien dans le
milieu hospitalier. Récemment,
Cédric Desjardins et Vincent
Séguin se sont lancé le défi
de fabriquer des planches
à roulettes.
CÉDRIC DESJARINS,
cofondateur de Crewlent
- J'ai quand même un bon
"background" technique,
je travaille dans
l'aéronautique. Je ne sais pas,
j'avais comme un instinct pour
savoir comment le faire.
- À partir de leurs recherches,
ils ont construit leur propreprs
modèles de planches. C'est ainsi
qu'est née Crewlent, une petite
entreprise artisanale.
VINCENT SÉGUIN,
cofondateur de Crewlent
- Il y a moyen de faire pas mal
n'importe quoi qu'on veut
en fait. Des fois, j'improvise
des trucs.- Et pour eux, pas qun
de faire venir du matériel
préconstruit à l'international.
- Ça ne fait aucun sens
au niveau environnemental
et surto que moi,
dans ma tête, je me disais;
quand tu pars une compagnie,
il faut que tu te mettes
les deux mains dedans.
- Les jeunes entrepreneurs
contrôlent chacune des étapes
de la production, mais pour
le reste, ils se laissent porter
par la vague.
- Je ne me crée aucune atten
depuis le début puis je pense
que c'est ça qui fait que ça
fonctionne.
- Dès ce soir, lteurs
de Crewlent exposent au
Jackalope, parmi les géants de
l'industrie présents au festival
de sports extrêmes.
- On a c se faire se faire se fe
demander pour des projets de
petites compagnies, des gens qui
voulaient "designer" des skates
ou "whatever." Jamais pour
quelque ssi gros
que ça.
- Chaque occasion de se faire
connaître est essentielle pour
de petites entreprises, comme
l'indique Micah Desforges,
producteur-exécutif
de l'événement.
MICAH DESFORGES producteur-
exécutif Jackalope
- Je pense que ça fait partie
de l'écosystème de;
mettre la lumière sur
des passionnés dont ces gens-là.
Il faut que tu sois visible, il
faut que tu bâtisses ta marque,
puis ça c'est un chemin qui ne
fait que, puis qui va
éventuellement faire évoluer
d'année en année.
- Même s'ils se considèrent
eux-même comme la relève,
Vincent et Cédric
déjà à aider d'autres passionnés
à percer le milieu.
- Je me dis, si je peux
commanditer des jeunes, puis
que ça évite une dr
les parents puis qu'eux puissent
comme avoir des skates comme
ils veulent et pas être obligé
d'attendre après, bien je trouv.
- Les deux fondateurs
de Crewlent ne veulentpas se mes
se donnent le droit de rêver.
- Si je peux gagner ma vie avec
ça, c'est sûr que ça serait
l'idéal.
- Ici Alexandra Piché,
Radio-Canada, Mo